foreign
[Music]
she can't be herself at a party cause
she's in her head
it's me if I think that she's pretty
enough
[Music]
I want to
but I can't save her could you just do
me a favor
tell her you don't love her even if it's
a lie make it sound true
break that spell she's under even if it
feels me do what you gotta do don't
leave it out don't break her phone don't
see her out don't tell her you'll call
Heather you don't love her
if you ever loved her at all
[Music]
I swear once you get yourself together
you show up
[Music]
but you and I both know deep down you're
too old to grow up
[Music]
no more maybe sorry some days have a
little Mercy on her could you just could
you just tell her you don't love her
even if it's a lie make it sound true
break that spell she's under even if it
feels me do what you gotta do don't
leave a doubt
her phone don't see her out don't tell
her you'll call
tell her you don't love her
if you ever loved her at all
[Music]
you can't leave a doubt
don't break her fall don't see her out
don't tell her you'll go
tell her you don't love her
if you ever loved her loved her at all
[Applause]